hey what can you explain what gives a in
politics this is a brush of weed every
day day changes all time out with cramp
talked about
america first and nationalism and all
the staff and tagged as winguard wessels
farmer i mean by data so switch
sarkodie de  line which this challenge
compris in also us to some you they let
the larger public
biddinghuizen mother meaning for people
who know what do you think you so it's
called i do so be cause there's such
thing as a dog whistle
wanjiru het i guess je  two
way in san diego very close eye on
remarkable together the educational here
spiders while saving grace ali b suites
here the honor coming to whistle what we that
's here in the last him here never that
's really eye patch trials the folder
pedicure miri live  in the shop of the
case may be there or races garg bills
de en thai milk jug bills there or
religious
jog bills ursem ik simples inner city
and urban
to refer the blog people to dozens in the
know who  is emilie in archives
slender club so beautiful figure the ivy league
you some people
bent shapiro use this time fire fell in
the balkans safely google youtube about
the real deal big and violence
who is not the focus on urban hour
innercity wherever you're talking on
black people  isabella black people
having gained my people having chance
is that is a dead switch the sound and
a few matters which give you know
what is meant to understand why and
order law and order it sounds on
redemption we have as a mini through the
direction stoney links te greater this is
within justice single and time i grant
ideas racing studios is wondering is a
signal and politicians tc
dory arm lost the code that lets timmy in
anaconda immergrün short black
people get too much cloud north terrace
and society to find time  is the similar
living al so teresa from connector church
history the price is policies like free
simple
step en fresh
use another example by rock hoessein
obama
to you mig  ht say that is the cheese take
every day be a dog whistle with the people
using it
use this single single ass
remark somone maybe was from iping most your
profile that understand our words the
turn certificate is the similar
sola fide yes mergers and forget to piece
or paper
hakkinda pwc any dpa group is both you
have a succeed this use the affectionate
how is using your to lure what is
being suggested or implied
by its use but so many en bag brand
congress of libido power just on those
but one s and so this  is that the
productive luck symbolic samsung
battery was the charm coincidence
en tie side of the talk about the
coincidence
of lure the number of us in this
industry
become coincidence and carbon dioxide in sounds
like i completely banana use of the
chairmen british part of
en thai afternoon  conspiracy is about
can firing te control industry of
government of the case may be
where is that change in politics of
using code language that sound and a few
espresso ve  ry specific and target
meaning the people who know where to
listen to and solve
the white supremacy step combine a chau
and they did it
who get from address say anything but
who support the line worse than
using and weather trump is coming
up  himself for is pim veth de
him
or a combination of the two mizuno with
the white supremacy voice selzers are
who here donald trump's code language
that's the idea who can great bonus show
coming up i him and member at joint
admin dot com of  peter and petra and dot
com slash t the task my show to get
instant access